alors les petits voyous voulaient qu'on
l'a vu à la télé oh non giscard
mitterrand le pape oui mais ils ont des
tubes we giscard ça commence toujours
par bonsoir madame bonsoir mademoiselle
bonsoir monsieur je suis venu comme à
chaque rendez vous télévisé vous
rassurer vous rassurer sur le franc qui
est fort qui est ce tabou qu'est tenace
le franc qui ne cesse de grimper
je parlais du franc suisse est
évidemment je le franc foucades d'étaler
ses étapes peu différent je voudrais
vous parler également de l'armée il ya
de plus en plus de femmes dans l'armée
quelle femme des femmes j'ai pas tant
que je les passe en revue de tangente en
est au moins de me rassure je me dis
avec elle
la france est un viol à paris au goût de
l'eau l'un dans l'autre
économiquement parlant la france arrive
maintenant on peut le dire nettement
avant le groënland des mitterrand le
dernier 33 toi et moi et mettez en bien
c'est vrai ouais je dirais françaises
français
je remercie l avance les électeurs qui
sont de plus en plus nombreux ce mec est
de plus en plus de françaises et de
français en france grâce à michel debré
qui avait dit à un moment à l'assemblée
nationale il faut que les françaises et
les français les phases des enfants sur
une grande échelle
patatras et feuilla il ya en france un
avion étonnant de le comprendre
c'est le seul avion qu'on nous a pas
pris d'assaut les autres avions les
détourner le nôtre nous retournons je
trouve ça très étonnant il ya autre
chose que j'ai pas bien compris c'est le
départ subit jacques chirac marqué je
n'aimais pas jacques chirac pour que je
n'y auront pas puisque evry vous mets
mes bien chers ferme ce troisième
dimanche après la pentecôte je pense que
les seigneurs voie puisque je raconte la
non excusez moi je suis complètement
mobile et par la main tendue aux
catholiques par monseigneur marche est
là j'ai peur qu'il ait commis là un pc
mortels et alors que le peuple
dia pape tu as parlé de monseigneur
lefebvre ici et à l'objet de l'écran oui
il est jeune et il m'a dit ça va mieux
avec le pape oui c'est parce qu'à la
messe du matin terminant lattara bah oui
quand elle commença c'est le pape c'est
chouette le pointu you pour dire cela il
me reste pas de nemo pour rester tombés
d'accord passé avec mangane toujours au
podium
et c'est un